Hi. My name is Magnus. I work with the Google Drive Team. We're going to look at the ASUS Anywhere
application, which allows you to interact
with content across many cloud storage
providers. And of course it has an integration with Google Drive API.  Let's have a look.
ASUS Anywhere is a highly practical integrated
cloud service management tool
that brings cloud services such as ASUS Webstorage, Google Drive and SkyDrive
together with shared files on My Computer and Local Area Networks (LAN)
using a single interface.
Today, almost all users use two to three computer devices,
including work and home PCs, tablet devices and cell phones.
They may also prefer certain cloud services as a result of using different platforms.
Using ASUS Anywhere to bring all these files together,
as well as the ability to search using keywords, helps users to find the files they are looking for.
The biggest advantage of using cloud services is the ability to get at the files you want anywhere, anytime.
From the developer’s standpoint, the important thing is the seamless user experience.
For example, when Google Docs is integrated with Google Drive and ASUS Anywhere,
you can go online to edit and share files, as well as manage them on your own computer.
Our goal is for users to get a great user experience when they buy ASUS products,
and it is for this reason that software services from multiple companies, including ASUS, Google and Microsoft, were brought in.
If we compare Google Drive, ASUS Cloud and Skydrive, all three services offer a comprehensive range of functions,
support a wide variety of platforms,
and perform well in terms of online file searches, downloads and uploads.
If you talk about which company’s “drive” is the best,
I believe that each has its own strengths.
But if you’re talking about Google Drive in terms of development, it has the following advantages:
1. Ease of integration:
Development using RESTful APIs makes it easier for developers to integrate Metro apps with Google Drive.
2. High execution performance: API execution performance is good.
3. Supports a complete range of features: Supports all the features that drives need.
4. Clear documentation and instructions: API documentation is comprehensive and easy for developers to read.
Integrating the Anywhere software using the Google Drive RESTful API is very convenient,
and the comprehensiveness of the features provided by Google Drive is excellent.
So integrating Anywhere with Google Drive
results in very few issues, just as with other drive services, and the API documentation is extremely clear.
In future, we hope that Google will provide functionality to support
streaming playback on the MS metro app built-in player.
Google has a diverse range of APIs,
but at this point we would particularly like to recommend the Google Geo Coding API,
some of the features of which are used in Anywhere strong search,
mainly its ability to translate GPS locations into geographical locations, which is really powerful.
For example, if the GPS coordinates of a photo are 22°N and 120°E,
the Google Geo Coding API is able to convert these coordinates into the Sinsing District in the city of Kaohsiung, Taiwan.